foreign
welcome to the third and last day of the
Jax diffuser Sprint
um I'm your host today uh Merve who has
hosted the two previous days with
amazing talks from stability AI from
Google and from hugging face is on her
well-deserved vacation so I'm apologo
I'm a machine learning arts engineer
here in hugging face and I'll be your
host today uh for the Talks by Andreas
from Jackson Control net by Boris and by
mag Mitchell on ethics
so our first talk is from Andreas he is
a researcher at Google on computer
vision and he will be talking to us
about Jacks and control mat it's a
pleasure to have him
um welcome Andreas and yes uh so yeah
I'm very excited to to see what you what
you have cooking so
um yeah I'll leave the floor to you I
will remove my screen and I'll add yours
okay thank you for the introduction upon
Ariel so my name is Andrea Steiner and I
work as a research engineer at Google
brain in computer vision research and
part of my time I also work on the flex
project that I'll be talking a bit about
today and sometimes I give internal
trainings about Jackson Flex to
newcomers in research to introduce these
Frameworks so I thought today I would
talk a bit about Jackson Flex in general
then I would talk a bit more
specifically about how this is used in
the control net Sprint that we're doing
together with some concrete examples and
I also have a bunch of slides about GPU
v-force by the way if you want to follow
along during the presentation or follow
up on some of the links later on I also
have a short link here where you can
download all the slides together with
the links and by the way here in the
background what you see this is not a
tpuv 4 pod but instead this is a TPU V3
pod and there will be some other nice
images later on from tpov4s
amazing thank you so much I'll leave you
with your presentation
thank you
so as I already said I'll be first
talked about Jackson flex and because
there has already been a talk about
um statefulness in checks and really
mostly concentrate on checks in this
first part and this will also be the
largest part and then the three other
parts that come later they'll be a bit
smaller
so first Jackson Flex
and you know with Jacks there's really
like one small weird trick that can
significantly accelerate your
computations and a bit later I'll show
you a second trick that will make it
even much faster so the first trick is
very simple instead of importing a numpy
as numpy you import numpy from checks as
jnp usually so often we have jnp as
checkstart numpy and at the same time in
the same programs you also have numpy
SNP and this allows us to control which
of the computation we want to have on
the host using numpy and most of the
computation will be done on the
accelerators using checks numpy and you
can see here we do a matrix
multiplication 5K by 5K which takes
around 10 or 11 seconds on a single CPU
core and if we do the same computation
using checkstore numpy this will
automatically be moved onto a connected
accelerator so a GPU or a TPU in this
case and we have a significant speed up
of like around 2000 you can also see in
this case if I want to time some
computation like here I would not only
do the matrix multiplication but I would
also add this block until ready and this
is because all the computations in
checks that asynchronous by default and
I also talk a bit more about the why
this is the case and what we need to
consider when we deal with asynchronous
computations
foreign
before I introduce some of the other
nice features of checks let me speak for
one slide about higher order functions
and here actually in most cases where I
talk about functions I really mean a
pure function so this means that um the
return value depends solely on the input
arguments and there's no side effect
going on so you know whatever this
function would do that doesn't result in
a change of the return value based on
the input arguments we will not consider
it so a pure function wouldn't have any
of those other components
okay so this is a signal um or a simple
and classical function and now if we
have a higher order function like for
example a function transformation this
looks similar to the example up here but
now the input arguments and the return
value they are functions themselves
so in the case of a function
transformation we might take a function
as an input and then we might return a
transformed function that does something
different but in this case it would have
him the same input and output signature
and of course when we do a function
transformation the input and output
signature that can also change as part
of the transformation
so let me illustrate this with a small
example imagine we have a single or a
simple function called add that simply
adds together two tensors and then we
have a very simple function
transformation that takes a function as
an input and it returns a function that
basically you know has the same input
and output signature but in this case
the return value will only be half of
the value that would have been returned
by the function that is a parameter to
this function transformation
so if we for example call this add
function with 2 and 4 we will get a
result of 6 but then if we first
function transform the add function with
this half function transformation this
expression here this will return a new
function and then in the same line we
execute this transformed function and we
see that the return value of the
transform function is in is indeed only
half of the return value of the original
function
this function Transformations they can
also be composed like here we call
whatever we apply half twice on the
original function at
and what you will also often see in
Python is that these function
Transformations they're simply being
written with the decorative syntax so
here the function transformation half it
would simply prefix it to the position
where we Define our function with that
symbol
yes so what can we use these function
Transformations for injects the first
example would be the vmap transformation
imagine here that we have a function
simulate that takes some position and
momentum as input parameters and it
expects those M2 parameters to be scalar
values but now we would want to do um
you know a computation of this simulite
function for a whole Vector of momentum
and the whole Vector of positions
evaluating this expensive function for
each of the combinations of position and
momentums so of course we could write
this as a simple um nested python Loop
like what I do here but the problems
with or the problem with this is that
um all the computations that will happen
sequentially and
which is a problem especially when use
accelerators
um all these computations there will be
or they will happen like one by one and
there's no potential of getting any
benefit from vectorizing the computation
and in this case you take checks.vmap to
the rescue so instead of doing a nested
Loop here I would take the function
simulate and then first checks vmap
transform it and so this simulate here
it will now contain or point to a
transformed function and this
transformed function is vectorized along
axis 0 in the first argument so this
would be the argument position then I
can take this transformed function and
transform it for a second time so here I
compose this checks VMA transformation
and this will yield a new function that
is vectorized both in the first and in
the second argument and then I can call
this vectorized function a single time
with this Vector of momentum and
positions
and now this vectorized m function it
will make full or it will take full
advantage of the vectorized computation
that's possible on Hardware accelerators
and this will result in a computation
that's a lot faster
the second interesting function
transformation that is very relevant for
machine learning work is the graph
function transformation and grad stands
for you know taking the gradient or Auto
grad and checks is actually a recursive
acronym of autograd and xla and xla is
exactly the second trick that makes the
computation faster that I'll explain a
couple of slides later
so imagine here that we have a function
that computes a scalar loss given rates
inputs and targets
now I can come or I can um transform
this loss function using checks.grad and
this will return me a function great
or sorry this expression here would be a
new function then evaluated with weights
inputs and targets it will return the
gradients of the value returned by the
original function so it will return the
gradients with respect to the loss or of
the loss with respect to the first
argument which is the weights here so
grads will have the same shape as weight
but every value in grads will be the
gradient of the loss with respect to
this weight
and then in a typical machine learning
program we would use it like this that
we have the loss function then we have
the update step function and in the
updates that function we first compute
the gradients then we take a small step
against the gradients and we return the
updated weights now you can see that
this updates step here it's still a pure
function because there are no side
effects and this is supposed to um the
code that we have down here because here
we have a data iterator and we iterate
through this iterator this will mean
that you know we update the um State
here and also when updating the state we
usually fetch data from a network or
from the hard disk so this is classical
side effects that we couldn't text
transform but inside this training Loop
we have the update step that is a pure
function and we'll see later that this
updates that can be function transformed
using jit or pmap
at this point you might be wondering how
can Jax analyze your functions and then
transform them
and this is what I will explain to you
in the next couple of slides at a high
level we have python code and then we
use Jacks to trace this python code
which will yield a check spur this check
spur can then be manipulated or
transformed by python code and we can
trace this transformation again and go
around in the circle and that's exactly
how we can compose these function
transformations
so let's first look at the tracing
[Music]
sorry about that
yeah so let's first look at the tracing
so
um
we have a mathematical function here
that would take the logarithm on the
basis of two
and we can write this in Python code
where we take the logarithm and then we
decided by are we divided by the
logarithm taken of the number two and
now the tracing is the process the text
is passed in the function here
and then transforms it into a texture
and you can see the check spray is
simply another way of this of describing
this original function you have on the
left side here
the big difference between Python code
and checks this is that python code is
very powerful and it's also difficult to
analyze because it's so powerful for
example we could overload these um
division operator here and inside this
overloaded division operator we can do
arbitrary code and arbitrary side
effects on the other hand if you look at
the check spur this is simply a list of
simple equations with inputs and outputs
which makes it you know a lot more like
restricted in terms of what it can
express but it also makes it a lot
easier to analyze and transform
so if you go a bit into more detail how
exactly this tracing process happens
first observe that the atomic or like
the Primitive computations that we do
the important from jax.lex
which gives this a set of um you know a
restricted set of these Primitives
and then when we trace the function so
in this case we look at the check for
the forward Jacobian transformation we
would call our function with a value of
x and x in this case it would be a
vector of size 2 um with ones
and what happens now for the tracings
that Jacks will look at this value that
we provide here and then it will create
a tracer object and this Tracer object
it will contain in this case um you know
the shape and the data type and also the
value and of this x that we provided but
then the tracing object can be observed
how it interacts with other tracing
objects and how it interacts with checks
Primitives
so if we walk through this function here
on the left side we'll see that for each
of the operations
and the Tracer object observes what
happens with it and checks will note a
um a corresponding line in the Jasper
and this way by simply analyzing the
interactions of the Tracer objects with
these Jacks Primitives we get to the
full um check spur that is the
equivalent of the computation we do in
this python function
and now the second step is with function
transformation of such a check spur in
this case I'm looking at the Jacobian
Vector product and this is the way how
we can compute the gradients of a
function
and first
um one important point for such a
transformation is that all the
underlying
um checks Primitives we have a rule for
them and in this case for you know like
Let Me Maybe
um make this semi-transparency because
the internals how this works exactly is
not so important the important part is
simply that we have a check expert then
we have some algorithm that processes
this checks per equation by equation and
we can transform these equations because
we have rules for the underlying
equations and then we can
algorithmically transform this checks
here and in the end we can execute this
code with a check spur and some concrete
values as input and in this case it will
compute the gradient for this given
function here
and now and this is kind of the you know
the important point about transforming
or about composing these Transformations
since this is simply python code we can
again trace this by providing traces for
the values of the concrete values here x
and t
and if you do this we get to a new check
expert and this new check expert is now
the
um transformed Jasper that we had as an
input here and because this is a check
spur itself we can now um continue this
cycle and take the check Square apply a
different python code on top of it that
transforms to check Square traced
execution of this python code and get to
a new check Square
so this is how we transform or how we
compose these Transformations and at any
point at any moment we can use the
python code to compute the actual
evaluation of such a check spur or
transform checks per or another thing we
can do is we can look at the check
expert which represents our entire
transform computation and then we can
compile that texture using xla
so consider for example this simple
function here where we add M2 tenses X
and Y and I imagine that one of the
tenses is a matrix and the other is a
simple Vector so if you want to compute
the output of this function we'll see
that first we'll need to broadcast the
vector to a matrix form and then we can
add this um two matrices together to get
to the result of the function
now the problem here is that if we do
this step by step we might have a lot of
memory transfers so xla and xli by
device stands for Accelerated linear
algebra so excelite will analyze our
computational graph and it will identify
um such blocks where we have two um
individual computations that can be
fused together and fusing together
really means that we will stream through
the y or through the values of y and x
and keep them in registers to perform
the entire computation so we don't have
to take the intermediate results and
store them back to memory
and this is benefits because when we do
this in a streaming way we will have the
same computation but fewer memory
transfers and memory transfers are very
expensive which might considerably slow
down our overall um computation and and
this value will not achieve you know the
maximum number of flops that will be
possible on a given platform
xli can also do some other things when
optimizing this computational graph like
you know optimizing the memory layout or
you can do rematch realization that we
can trade some compute for memory or the
other way around or you can even you
know like strip large parts of our
computation because we don't depend on
them for computing the output values
so why this lengthy explanation of how
checks works and what we can do with
them this you know with xla on this
check space in the end this is really to
introduce
um the
chip or actually I already mentioned it
here right yeah so here like you know
it's the jit function transformation
that you call um or that we'll use xla
to transform your uh check spur into an
optimized M version that will be
executed on accelerator and this is
really what you will do later on you
will design a function like this
function here which computes a square of
a provided value and then we will apply
jit on this function to compile it and
to
um execute it on a GPU or on a GPU
and there are some sharp edges when you
do that you need to be aware of and one
is that these functions need to be pure
I already mentioned this a couple of
times in the presentation but this is a
really important point so imagine for
example that what happens when you have
a print statement here now we know that
when um jit wants to compile your
function it first needs to trace it we
also know that the output value will not
depend on this print statement so um
this print statement will not be part of
the Jack spur
and we also now know because we know how
chasing works that when we call jit of
square you know nothing happens at this
moment but only later when we execute
this um cheated version providing a
specific value here only at this moment
we will have the data type and shape
available that will require for the
tracing and when we do the first tracing
we will see this print statement as a
side effect but because this print
statement is now not part of the check
spur that represents our computation
when we do exactly the same statement
for a second time then we already have a
compiled version of square a jit
compiled version of square so we will
use this cached version and this time
despite we have the correct output
result the side effect will not be
executed for a second time
by the way if you want to do like things
like a print statement during the
computation where you also have access
to the values you can use checks debug
print which is a similar
um
you know a similar
function or
yeah like a similar function to the
original print
and by the way another thing is also
it's fine to use any kind of state
inside the transformed function but you
should not depend on state that goes
across these function boundaries where
you apply the function transformations
a second important part is to understand
how control flow Works inside these
functions imagine that here we would
want to implement the multiplication by
unrolling it in a python Loop now if you
try to cheat compile such a function you
will get this somewhat cryptic
concretization type error this
concretization type really means that at
this position here where you look at the
value of N and this value is not
available and it makes sense that this
value is not available because we want
to chip compile this function to work
with any values so when we did compile
it the actual value of n will not be
available and that's also why this um
python control flow here cannot be
unrolled because we don't have a
concrete value for n and this is what
creates this error
on the other hand it's fine to do
control flow that's dependent on the
shape or data type because in xla every
time one of the input arguments has a
new shape or data type we need to
recompile the function anyways
so the shape and data type they're known
at compile time
if you really want to implement the
function like here on the left side you
could do this by specifying static Arc
nums and static Arc nums would really
mean that every time we recompa or every
time we execute this function if n has a
new value we would recompile it so this
way the cached compact functions will
have n as part of their cache key
effectively
the second option would be that we use x
select control flow from the checks.lax
package and this way we wouldn't need to
trace this while loop anymore but the
while loop would be expressed as um you
know as a check slacks primitive and
this can later be translated directly to
a um to an xla instruction
um a last sharp edge that I wanted to
mention here is that all computation in
checks happens asynchronously so if we
have um some expensive computation like
for example here evaluating a model
when you call and the cheat compiled
version of this so here we have outputs
equal you know the output of this
function and the python code will
continue running here even though the
computation is not finished yet
now what happens when you print for
example the shape of the outputs because
the shapes they're already known this m
will also happen asynchronously so this
print statement it can happen while our
outputs are still being computed on the
other hand if you want to print um like
the actual values of the outputs at this
moment your python thread would be
blocking until the computation is
finished and that's also something
that's important to be aware of because
for example in your train Loop if you
print and the loss and the loss is
returned by your update step and you do
this in the same thread then your
computation would be blocked at this
moment until or your passing thread will
be blocked until the computation is
finished
and if you do this
then you lose the benefits of being able
to do python code like iterating through
your data set at the same time that you
could do the computation on the
accelerators
so this essene computation is a simple
way of using single threaded python
programs that do input processing in
Python at the same time as the
computations being done on the GPU or
TPU
yeah I've already mentioned accelerates
a couple of times and of course one
thing you can do to accelerate your
computation is to use a more powerful
accelerator and we can use them
checks.chip to make good use of this
powerful Excel right this another thing
you could do is that you connect
multiple accelerators to your computer
and if you want to do this we will use
the pmap transformation
remember from earlier that we had this
vmap that takes a function and
transforms it so that the transformed
function can take a whole batch of input
elements like here would be a single
element a returning a single element and
here would be a batch of elements and
also a batch of elements that's returned
now we can replace the vmap by pmap
which has a similar signature to vmap
and if we do this then the computation
will happen on Parallel on all the
attached devices
one important difference here is that
pmap expects that the shape of the input
values has a leading axis that is equal
to the number of attached accelerators
and you see here that if you have a
batch of n values we would usually
reshape this batch to First have a
dimension of D for the number of devices
and then the dimension of n divided by D
and now also each of the device would
only see this part of the shape here
so the first axis that is per number of
elements per number of devices this
disappears during the computation
because the computation happens on these
devices in parallel in one of the last
slides I also show you a different way
how you can perform the same thing using
the updated checks.jet
and now two slides about flex and flex
is really a neural network library for
use with Jax and you might have heard
about Haiku also and um Haiku is uh you
know has exactly the same function as
Flex for constructing neural networks
and Haiku is the library that's mainly
used inside deepmind and flex is the
library that's main list inside Google
but you can also use both those
libraries at the same time and combine
them
then there's other libraries in the
checks ecosystem you know like giraffe
for computing neural network or for
computing graph neural network libraries
optics for implementing optimizes or
diffracts for um Computing differential
equations and the point of this slide
here is that uh you know opposed to some
other Frameworks like for example
tensorflow checks is simply the base
framework lying
unifying everything and then there's a
lot of smaller modules on top of this
that can be used interchangeably and
they all use checks for the computation
and interoperate through jacks
you'll also see that some parts that are
important for machine learning like for
example data loaders are not actually
implemented as part of checks so in this
case if you'll be we would be using um
tensorflow data sets or Pi torch data
loaders and in the case of the control
net the script that we provide you with
we are using the pytorch data like the
loaders for the input pre-processing
so let's look
um a bit in more detail at Flex
and you know that was an excellent talk
by Sabrina milke on day two of this um
Sprint so I highly recommend you
watching this talk where Sabrina goes
into a lot more detail about how um
state is handled inside checks
Frameworks and there's also a great
um documentation from Flex that goes
into more detail of the module life
cycle and if ever you run into um you
know surprising Behavior with flex
modules I recommend you also having a
look at this documentation here
but you can see in a nutshell Flex is a
way and that allows you to Define your
neural networks with very little code so
for example here we would Define a
multi-layer perceptron by instantiating
two dense layers and applying a
non-linearity in between
so mflex really helps you with them
State handling and it provides you with
predefined layers like this um you know
this linear layer here but we also have
more complicated layers like for example
um self-attention with autoregressive
caching
and you can also see that the state
handling like for example what happens
to the parameters of this NN dense this
is handled by flux in a transparent way
so you don't need to carry around these
states every time that you use such a
module
and another thing you can see is that
here we have a single function that both
um sets up our modules and then also
applies the forward path and this is
very beneficial when you have a more
complicated modules because often you'll
have some control Logic for the setup
and then for the forward pass and having
this in a single function allows you to
reduplicate this logic
another thing that you see here is that
you don't need to define the input
shapes or you don't need to Define
anything based on the input shapes when
you define new modules and this is
because we have shape inference and this
internal shapes they'll be determined
the first time that we call this module
with um some actual input data which
will Define all the input shapes
so this is what your code would look
like when you define modules and now
it's important to understand if you want
to use these modules in the checks
program you'll be calling them through
these two functions model dot in it the
model.apply and these two functions have
pure checks functions so this is the
difference to the function here right
because here we instantiate this stance
and then we apply X or we we compute the
output value given X as an input value
but in this function here we don't
provide any state but the state instead
will be handled by Flex behind the
scenes on the other hand when we're in
stateless checks land we need to provide
the state to each of these functions
because these are pure functions
so the important thing to understand is
that when you call model.in or
model.apply then Flex internally will
set up a couple of things such that you
can then you know use this code inside
your modules even though this is not
pure functions anymore
okay with this let's get to the control
net example
and you know the first thing and this is
by the way the entire code of like our
training script that we're using for the
for this Sprint so the first good news
for you is that there's actually very
little checks Flex specific code in this
example and most of the code is really
about input processing interfacing with
tensor sorry with hugging face Hub or
um
sending metrics to writing biases so
very classic like machine learning code
that you even if you haven't used um
Jackson Flex before are probably already
familiar with
the two parts that are a bit more
specific to Jackson Flex is first the um
Trend step here and then second the
train Loop down here
and for the train Loop we prefer usually
in checks not to have some abstraction
like you know tensorflow Keras or
pytorch lightning that would take
control of our training Loop but instead
we would prefer to write out the
training Loop because this makes it a
lot easier to change things through code
instead of changing the behavior through
configuration but it also makes that you
have some more you know like lines of
code in your example that implements the
actual training Loop
yeah so the train step I already told
you before that we would try to take the
largest possible pure function and then
get compiled this large function this is
also why you know like this largest
possible function is usually the
function called train step and you can
see here that everything you want to
change in the train step like the state
that contains the optimizer State or the
parameters or or also the random number
generators that are used for generating
Randomness for example in the diffusion
process all these things that are
changed during the training step we need
to return them from the train step
so you can see here that some of these
parameters like State and train RNG
they're both input arguments and return
values
inside the trend step you would see that
we have a compute loss function then we
take the gradient from this and then we
apply the gradients to the state and if
you look inside this data class that is
State here you'll see that we use the
gradients to compute the new optimizes
state and then to compute the updated
parameters and you see here also that
when we use this pattern of updating a
data class where internally the data
class is updated with that self.replace
we would then take this return value and
store this new state that this new state
is what would be returned from the train
step and then in the main tube we would
keep updating this state that is
contained in this variable state
and then you know in our example we have
multiple accelerators so instead of
checks.jit we would use checks.pmap and
now an interesting thing when you use
pmap is that all these State variables
that you have here we need to replicate
them manually so you'll see in the code
that we use these checks it used to
replicate and you'll also see if you
want to do something with return value
we'll usually call unrepla unreplicate
on the return value so that you would
get um one of the copies from this
multiple devices that are attached
yeah a final slide about what we do in
the control net example is for setting
up profiling I think this illustrates
two things that I said about the chip
compilation and asynchronous processing
so the first would be if we want to
profile our train step before starting
the profiling and before ending the
profiling we would make sure that the
previous computation is finished by
calling block until ready
on one of the return values a second
thing that's important to consider is
that we would never compile the first
step but we would only start at Global
step equal to one and here Global step
is incremented starting at zero and this
is because the train step if you go back
here
um the train step so this means it will
also be chit compiled and this means the
first time we execute the train step
it's at this moment that the chip
compilation will happen and if we
already started
um the
profiling at step 0 then we would
profile the entire
um like chip compilation which would
create a lot of additional events that
are not so interesting for our profiling
purposes
yeah with this some words about the TPU
V4 platform and everything that I tell
here is from this paper that has come
out just a couple of weeks ago and if
you're interested into the technical
details then I highly recommend reading
up in the paper
so the first thing that's important to
understand is that you know we have
these really large pots and in this case
one pot is an equivalent is 4096 chip
and these chips they're glued together
on a single PCB where we have four four
chips and one PCB it's also one of these
boards that will be attached to a single
computer which you will control as part
of the Sprint
but now the slightly confusing thing is
that each of those chips contains two
cores
so we have 4096 chips but the double
number of course on those chips and now
there are two different configurations
you can use this course individually or
you can like excellent can treat them as
a single device in which case you will
only see four attached devices this is
exactly the configuration that we use
for our M Sprint so when you call checks
device can't you see the number four
even though when you create such a VM
the um topology will be called v48
because we have eight
um cores on such a configuration
a second thing that's very interesting
with the TPU architecture is how these
chips are interconnected we have a very
high bandwidth intercore interconnect
and this intercore interconnect is
arranged in a 3D pattern so that each of
the chips has a connection to six
Neighbors
and now we have these um small cubes
with 64 chips in them and if you want to
connect this and actually these
connections here they're hardwired but
if we now want to connect these cubes to
a larger topology and we will use
Optical circuit switches for this and
the beauty of optical circuit switches
is that we can rearrange these smaller
cubes in a flexible way
this allows us for example to have them
thoroughly or like a configuration like
a Taurus or it also allows us to have
another configuration like a twisted
Taurus and these different
configurations they are optimal for
different communication patterns which
can be optimized for different
computational workload that you have
so as I said before there's like much
more details about the TPU architecture
in this paper if you want to know more
with this we already made it to the end
and you know because most of this talk
was more geared towards people who are
new to Jackson Flex I thought I would
also mention a couple of features
um that are more recent for people who
are already very familiar with checks so
they can also see some interesting new
new things coming up
the first of this is that since
checks041 we actually have a new
distributedchecks.array interface and
using this checkstore error interface
for example allows you to
um you know to rewrite your code that is
using pmap in a nice array among many
other things I mean the main advantage
of this distributed areas is really for
model parallelism but because that's
something we didn't touch on um in these
slides I'm going to illustrate it with a
pmap example so what we have here on the
left side is a computation very similar
to the one that I showed you on earlier
slide
and where we apply a pmap and we need to
manually call replicate before calling
pmap and this um the new checks arrays
you can actually take the input arrays
and then apply a charging to them and
then you can simply call jax.jit on the
train step
and you don't need to replicate your
inputs and outputs anymore but checks
will do this transparently for you
so this is like a nicer way of writing
the pmap but it's also a much more
powerful way um of writing your program
for a model parallelism
a second thing that's been introduced
recently is the short map M transform
and the short map transform basically
allows you to retain some manual control
when you use pitch it that does you know
like most of the heavy lifting for you
automatically and you might be wondering
why you would want to have some manual
control over these things and if you
want to know the details or like an
illustration of one of the cases where
this can be beneficial I recommend you
have a look at this paper
and here's just some quotes that
basically shows you how you could apply
a short map for computing
um for doing a model parallel
computation of a mat mile but now we
don't really have time to go into the
details here but if this looks
interesting to you then make sure to
have a look at this map documentation it
has this example in more detail and then
also a bunch of more advanced model
parallel examples
and finally
um since recently
um checks also supports integration with
Triton and there's like a dialect called
them Palace that allows you to also use
um
you know Triton with a checks transforms
essentially
but also here that's you know more kind
of a name dropping for people who are
interested in Triton so that you know
this is implemented in checks as well
with two links to follow up and read
more about this
yeah with this we're at the end of the
presentation
um and I'd be happy to answer any
questions from you
thank you so much for your presentation
Andreas this was really uh informative
and yeah I we have a few questions in
the chat
um I will select two maybe for the
interest of time
um
so we have Alex McKinney and commanduru
with quite a few questions
um one of the questions that I think
it's uh interesting here
is from Alex about the topology so he's
asking what is the topology for smaller
TPU pods uh say four like we have in the
Sprint so for those who don't know in
the Sprint we will be giving uh some TPU
v-force to to the participants uh if you
were interested in that and you haven't
joined yet feel free to go to the to the
live stream on YouTube uh video
description and you can see a GitHub
link with the instructions but yeah yeah
so this is the question from Alex what's
the topology for smaller TPU pods like
the four we have in the Sprint
it's a great question so that's exactly
what we see here on the left side so
during this Sprint you'll have one of
these parts that is attached to one
computer so we you will have these four
M chips with eight cores but because the
way how um these four chips are
configured you won't see the course
individually but you will instead see
only the four chips as like single cars
but it also means that each of the
course has like doubled the compute and
doubled the memory of um of a single car
and these steps will all be directly
connected
um through like a interface with the
host computer and they will have
connections between each other so for
example in our exact like in our Sprint
code then we call the
checks.lex.p mean then the gradients
that will be
averaged directly by the connections on
the PCB between these four chips and
they don't have to go forth and back to
the host
awesome thank you so much and yeah
commandero had a similar question uh
that I think you answered in this uh
watch he was asking why are we getting
four for Jack's device count and not
eight uh but I think that's what you
just answered and the same question or a
similar question is how can we use all
eight cores yeah yeah let me just
reiterate here and we you know you do
have the eight chords but xlay like
fuses two cores together each so and you
only see four devices but you get the
full compute of the eight cores
so for example if you wanted to split
this course and have eight devices then
each of the devices would only have half
the compute and half the memory so this
wouldn't make your competition faster
even though you have um double the
number of course
and you know in in our example because
we have fairly large models it would
even be
um like not a good idea because you like
you would have half the memory so you
know the model wouldn't even fit with
the same web size anymore in this case
yeah and then uh one last question
before you wrap is What's the total
memory size uh for for the device that
we got
um um you know I always like mix I think
it's 32 GB for the 32 or 64. depends on
yeah I always mixed two up but I I'll
check afterwards and I'll reply on this
card
perfect and yeah and then also in the in
the Sprint details we have all the
information there for the people
participating so yeah well thank you so
much Andreas for your time and for this
amazing talk uh and I hope to see you
soon right bye
all right everyone so now we will have
uh joining us Boris and Boris is the
creator of Dolly mini which is the first
uh text to image model that to go really
viral and for those who don't know this
is actually started in a Sprint like
this so in 2021 there was a jack Sprint
uh with hugging face and that's uh the
the first Ali mini version emerge from
one of the Sprints so this is going to
be very
uh exciting to me and to everyone here
to here a bit of the story The
developments and what's next for for
Dolly mini crayon and so welcome Boris
hi everybody
so I'm thank you for the introduction uh
apolinario so I'm Boris dayima and um I
worked on dalimini during the first uh
Jax event has um as I was introduced
um so as you see like on the middle it's
actually the icon that we had for the
lemonade
um this is actually I don't know if you
recognize but it's supposed to look like
an avocado armchair that was like a
a very important illustration done by
the original Dali by open air yes so we
were like let's try to generate it and
we add that cute icon
um so like that's a cool logo to have
and now it became Korean
um so it all started with this event and
now it became like a website that that a
lot of people use all the time so it's
quite exciting to see like how these
products can go by starting with the the
Jack's hugging face print and now like
having so many users
um so I'm gonna try to tell you a bit
about the story of hoyta burn how it
evolved and hopefully give you a bit of
inspiration for your event a lot of
these things apply for you too even
though you know you're gonna walk more
on a diffusion model
but I'm gonna try to to keep it a bit
General and give you practical advice
so quickly what is the lemonade the
limit is a is a simple model that
basically you type text and you get an
image out of it
um so one of the first fun one that we
had was the avocado armchair the one you
saw initially that looks a bit different
because I think the prompt is actually
logo of an avocado armchair this one you
get the the full real avocadometer it
looks pretty cool I think like the the
here it doesn't look pretty comfortable
for your back in some of them
but otherwise they look pretty cool
um what's interesting with this is like
you know initially it started with very
very simple prompts like we're maybe
just throwing view of the beach and
we're happy and then we became a bit
more creative as the model was working
and for example here I have the Eiffel
Tower landing on the moon
um but then at some point you know we
grew the model it became daily Mega when
uh when it went to a much larger size
and what was interesting is people were
able to do very creative films so I
really like that one that's one of my
favorite teddy bears thieves in a store
CCTV and it's really look like teddy
bears you can see like rubbing a store
and uh what's interesting about this
model I think is like that the quality
is not is not as high but the the
information is so well compressed
because we wanted just something that
works so we there's not many tokens and
all and I think somehow it's still one
of the silly one of the models that's
able to do the the craziest thing so you
can type very interesting prompt maybe
you don't get the the best quality based
on what you would have nowadays
um but you get you get that kind of
stuff that you cannot get anywhere else
and to me it's still amazing like how
how did it even draw something like that
it's still a it's still a bit magical
even seeing it working
so quickly about how did it start
um there was that open AI paper but
daily at the time you couldn't test it
but they had a cool a few cool
illustrations and they had a lot of
interesting technical details
and I saw that tweet about with an
example an illustration of a baby Daikon
radish inner tutu working a dog and and
you had those illustrations of a little
radish walking the dog and I thought wow
that that's really amazing and I was
okay I want to learn how to build it uh
by the way this prompt is still crazy
hard to to do even if you try on Delhi
too uh it doesn't work as well
um it doesn't work really well at all to
be fair in any of the diffusion models
I've seen so it's quite interesting you
know I actually want to sign out I
wonder if you know the different model
versus like the auto regressive models
which are like tele Mini
um and W1 are able to to do more complex
things in some ways
so six months later uh more or less
hugging face organized that competition
um and
you know when when I was like I want to
learn how to build that the first thing
I did I opened the paper I opened the
blog post and it was really really hard
to understand
um it was very complex and I think you
you cannot you need to not be too scared
about these papers some of them like the
daily paper I probably read it
more than 50 times
um and each time I graduate I'm sure if
I open if I open it again right now you
see something different and you learn
something new all the time and then you
have those references to other papers
and you cannot be scared of going
through it still nowadays there's a lot
of paper I don't understand but need to
go through it so the cool thing about it
is like you get
um you get in this event you get to
learn how to use Jax flux which is
really cool which probably many of you
have never used it's different from by
torch but in the end you know when you
build a model whether you build it in
Keras Fighters Jacks there's a few
differences but most of them work the
same way you know you have layers
pre-built for you dense layers
convolution layers you stack them and
there's a few few different season
tracks is a bit more different in some
ways with the state full versus
stageless abstraction
but uh but in the end you know you can
learn it and and you see it's quite
magical and quite uh quite interesting
what is cool in this event you get also
support from both uh some Google
engineers and hiring face Engineers
which is which is a really nice
opportunity so I definitely recommend
you to join it and the last piece that's
really cool is you get access to other
CPU VMS it's quite addictive you know at
the time I thought I had a pretty cool
computer
Nvidia 20 2018 TI which is pretty nice
that's you know it's no match to the CPO
VM so take advantage of it play with it
you quickly get addicted
um so when the when I saw that I
immediately posted the the idea to do a
daily project and I like to read it
because it's fun it's like it would be
cool to recreate something like Delhi I
can see some challenges though difficult
paper the main Concepts could be
simplified availability collection of
data set the model used was gpt3 not
sure if interesting results can be
obtained with smaller models actually
it's not correct it was not gpd3 but
it's kind of the the same architecture I
would say
it may require more time to implement
remember it's actually a short short
Sprint in the end and I like also I
don't believe a public version is
available so maybe it will be easier to
just do it in by torch I have no
experience yet with flex tracks so when
you look at that that looks kind of
scary I think uh somebody proposing that
project
what's been is actually a bunch of
people decided to join me like yeah
great idea let's do it
and um and what is fun is we actually
did it so it's pretty nice
um we had a very tight timeline so from
the project proposal so the most
submission there's about only three
weeks and the first part is just trying
to figure out how to do it
um so it's quite interesting
it's very um those are very ambitious
project I think in these teams you need
to you need to
have a few price management skills uh
you're gonna work with other people it's
important that you you keep yourself
updated all the time list the tasks uh
so that you so that you know people can
organize themselves
um and what's important like there's a
lot of tasks that can be performed
simultaneously so for example preparing
the data set preparing the demo maybe
there's some sub PCS that that can fit
together and it's important to do that
and and see how people can organize
themselves around it
what will happen is like um because it's
all a team of volunteers people
self-assign some tasks um I would say
you know it's it's normal that some
desks are difficult you may not succeed
be open talk about it within your team
what's important is you need to have a
bit of accountability or you know if you
say I'm gonna take care of this part and
nothing happens and people depend on you
please be mindful on that
um some members are going to be more
involved than the layers and and it's
okay what is what is interesting is like
you know it's a marathon it's a Sprint
but I think you know it's interesting to
join because at the end you you can
learn something and you will probably
learn a lot and it will be a very unique
experience so it's very fun
something that uh you should start with
when you have your idea try to find the
papers that are relevant to to your
problems
so we read a lot of papers and we read
uh read them many times so those are the
three most important paper the zero shot
takes three image generation for us was
the the daily paper
um changing Transformers for high
resolution images basically was mainly
um what we used was we need our image
encoder which came from that paper and
bought is about sequence to sequence
models so it's it's kind of a basic
paper in the end I mean not basic in the
sense that's really it's really applies
to any kind of model that transform a
sequence to another sequence but we went
back to this paper because you can learn
some Concepts that are going to be
important so don't be scared about
revisiting simple things I think I was
revisiting even like the transformer
architecture many times
so go back to that you don't have a lot
of time and it's important to Leverage
The Open Source ecosystem
to build to build your prototype
fortunately you know there's a lot of
code that you can use so the the first
thing is like finding the data set that
can be appropriate maybe you can build
some maybe you can start with something
that will work and then try on yours it
can be a point of failure at the time
for us we had conceptual captions and
yfcc that were applicable nowadays
there's a lion has a lot of really cool
data set you don't have to download it
all you can download Based on the memory
you have you know only 10 million
examples or less can be sufficient
10 million seems like a big big number
but it will fit easily on your on your
memory
um
also you know at the time it was a bit
hard to download you have to figure that
out so maybe you can have a member to to
find out how to do it
so the library to download images
img2 data set it's really nice because
you you give your list of data that can
be in a lot of format and you cannot put
it in a lot of different normal weather
web data sets CF data or or just files
so something else is like it's good to
use open source models for us we use
clip which again we actually use the
pre-trained about model
that we fine-tuned
and use open source code and I think you
know the I would say like in hanging
fish you have a training script for
everything and it's actually true in our
case we we based it on on a
summarization model that was already
existing and you start with something
that work and you see can can you make a
trend and you slowly updated based on
your needs and it's really add more
complexity based on what you want but
don't start I would say don't start
everything from scratch start with
something that work and little by little
modify it because that that will be a
way easier it's important to have a good
Baseline and a first prototype that
works a good resource also is that if
you go to listen range reports whatever
paper exists he pretty much has a repo
for it so you will find some good
inspiration in that in it also they are
really well documented there's a really
nice 3D me that explains quickly how it
relates to other papers
so it's a good reference I'm going to
talk quickly about daily mini now how it
works
um so
basically we have a sequence to sequence
model here are the inputs for example it
will be a sentence in French
and here are the output and it could be
a sentence in English so here it would
be a translation model
a sequence to sequence are often used
for
translation or summarization some
numeral where you first get a sequence
of inputs and then you get another
sequence in output
it's not the same structural as the list
so here we were like a little creative
because
um daily they have the entire sequence
in one
all all concatenated together so you
have the text then you have a special
token that tells you okay now I'm
starting to Output the image
so you can do things a bit differently
it's good to see like okay can I use
that type of model and can I apply it to
my to my specific problem
and here is the architecture of delimini
so what's interesting is that you have a
caption you have an image the caption
goes to a bot model so about is sequence
to sequence so you get the that sequence
of text that is tokenized that here
becomes just a sequence of discrete
inputs and then on the other side you
have the image use that thing that you
are going to look at what it is but it's
a VQ gun encoder it's an image encoder
basically and it's called it's like my
um my image I'm gonna transform it into
a series of discrete tokens so of
discrete numbers
and then I'm gonna try to go from one to
the other so here I'm gonna try to get
my input of text tokens I predict what
would be the image tokens and I just
have a cross entrepreneurs to compare to
what is the grand truth I'm gonna go
between two more details on that but
these modules are are not used a lot for
some of the diffusion model but they are
used actually in
in party for example using the same
principle you also have Muse it uses
discrete tokens
um so it's very it's very interesting
that it can still be applied in some of
the recent state-of-the-art models
and once you have that the inference is
very easy because you give your text you
have to put a series of tokens which
correspond to an image so you had your
your week again encoder which goes from
the image to the tokens you have the
reverse transform basically which goes
from the tokens back to an image and
what we would do
um on those it's optional but we would
rank them with clip clip is a model that
tells you how good your image matches
the caption so then it can select what
are the top ones it's really optional
but it adds a bit of quality when you
have like a noisy outputs or outputs
that don't really match the the model
so it's it's a multi-modern uh it's a
it's multi-modal and basically you try
to maximize the cosine similarity
between text and image so you uncut text
to a certain embedding Vector you encode
an image in another embedding vector and
then you just multiply them together and
you want them to be as close as possible
when they are normalized and that's what
will but the embeddings together
clip is used by the way for other
application it's also used for stable
stable diffusion they use the text
encoder of clip so it's very powerful
powerful model that gets understanding
of text to all the images
uh one of the steps we add which is one
of the many steps was functioning the
week again
so the week again is the image encoder
what does I'm gonna go very briefly on
it but you have an image and you try to
transform it into discrete token so you
have a variational autoencoder but at
the bottom of it what you try you try to
match the embedding to a code book that
is discrete I'm using losses in a smart
way you know you get that to train and
you get that to have a finite finite
numbers of codes that correspond each to
kind of a patch so one of these numbers
for example 94 could mean okay it's a
green patch 33 convince a yellow patch
with a red dot on it it's a bit more
complex than that because in the end
they all you have a convolution applied
on it so the old kind of interact with
each other but that's the base idea
under the Gan part of the name is based
on the fact that the the original model
is more like a vqa by open AI
um so when you do that when you do that
directly what happens is your image can
be a bit blurry your encoder try to
minimize the the loss so you have a bit
of
you have a bit of blurred details
because it tries to minimize the square
loss but when you add organelles to it
what it will have it adds more details
to it so the Cuban that's what they do
they add organelles to it and you get a
bit more details which translates some
more quality I would say
so we translate we functioned it and I'm
gonna go really quickly to it but it was
not very good at faces because there's a
lot of options that weak again we could
use and we use the F16 which compresses
the image much more
um the reasons like at the end we wanted
just a model that works
um F16 compresses it more and it's fewer
tokens that means it's faster to train
at the end of the day we don't have much
time to train
so it was I think it was a good choice
it was hard to train at the time on tpus
because some of the operations that were
in a pytorch code were not supported in
your in the Sprint you're going to use
Jack skull so everything works perfectly
enough to worry about it
but we ended up printing gpus to try to
find fine tune it a bit more at the end
I think I think we we use that one but I
don't know it improve the that much the
the video game it was actually a
challenge what's important you know when
you have a roadblock it was not
essential you know we used the
pre-trained model so we had pre-training
model for a lot of the parts of the
pipeline this part didn't work but was
not essential it's important to move on
so one of the person was on it that was
me and um and it didn't work that well
we still used it but um then tanishq for
example tried to see if we could make it
work on tpus to function it a bit more
but that's why it's important to have
many members you know and and work on
those tasks that are a plus but be able
to move on and work with something else
in the meantime
preparing the data set is a big part so
I would I would say you know try to
prepare them early at one or two members
of your team work on it you don't want
your data set loaded will be the
bottleneck so you need to try it test
also you know loading your data and
reconstituting the images so that you
get uh you get what you have for us we
use the web data set format which is
fast and efficient
um to uncut the images and when they
were in token we use hugging face data
sets for it because of all the
convenient functions that that are there
so the Prototype now this is the fun
part I'm gonna go a bit to to the code
what we did we used
um we looked what was the most similar
and so we have that about model that
goes from a sequence to another sequence
and there's a there's already a model in
the hugging face library that can do
that
the main difference for us is we want to
separate the encoder tokens to the
decoder tokens typically you know you'll
summarize maybe you have shared tokens
between the two we need a few
adjustments because we're gonna use our
image tokens but it's basically the same
model otherwise
so what's fun maybe some people will
find it's a bit dirty a bit likely but
we import the flexibot module for the
hacking from the hacking face
Transformers library and we just
override it with another module so we do
class flexbox module of flex bar module
and here we just change the setup method
and and that's all we did and that was
pretty much our model
and um and then we have a few other
models you know over time where where we
changed things so I can show you you
know the latest version of the code
quickly but um if you go to the LA menu
over time you know I did a lot of um
I did a lot of other methods
and um
and there's a lot of still import from
the Transformers Library
and if I go to to the models
you see like flexible attention since
since uh still inherits from a a module
that's from hagging face and I just
override whatever model methods I want
to change and I go to flexbox module
and I still override some methods and I
think you know you can just copy paste
also and modify it just I wanted to
benefit to what other updates they would
do but things break sometimes
so this pros and cons
um so we did a quick model sizing
because there's different models there
so we we saw like what can fit in our
architecture what can fit in our GPU at
the time we use TPU v38
nowadays you have v48 which are even
better
and um you want to first check what is
the max batch size you can fit in memory
typically the bigger batch size the
better there's no reason to have a small
batch size anymore
depending on your data set obviously if
you don't have much data sometimes it
changes
but then you know you want to do some
gradient accumulation maybe to see
what's the if you can fit on your small
batch size let's say you can fit only
100 samples you're gonna do gradient
accumulation and look at in the
applications what are typical batch
sizes that are used
um and try to match it or be as close as
possible to it
it will help your model train if the
batch size is too small it won't work
really well
it's important to do a search of
learning ratio there's hyper parameter
optimization there's tons of primarily
you can optimize if you optimize one I
would say the learning rate to spend
time on it because it changes a lot of
things
we spent one day to optimize it and you
see we did a quick search we did a few
experiments um Khalid was running on the
the experiments on the different tpus
the best
and then we have only three days left to
train our model so when I cook it it may
be time to train our model so we start
training it
and as we train it even before we
trained it we had also some people in
our team
um tanishq was working on that
um working on having a demo through
experiment is it trending correctly
because you trained us three days and
immunities doesn't work you're gonna
waste your time you can prepare
immediately your pipeline to how do I do
inference on it and it lets you find
issues quickly so for example you know
initially we had little things the image
didn't appear to be right but then it
was a Our Generation pipeline that was
not completely correct but quickly we
were outputting Ira review of the of the
beach during the day and during the
night and we had those little Blobs of
images which were not really correct
they were really like random blobs but
what was cool is like the the image by
night was kind of dark and the image by
there was pretty light or was lighter so
we thought okay maybe the model is
trending maybe it's doing something good
it was a bit after when they were gonna
see quicker examples but but it's really
important to implement a pipeline early
not not don't keep it for the end it
doesn't have to be your fancy or final
demo you can just
just use a notebook for development it's
great user collab or regular notebook
and and everybody can develop and work
on it and and play with the model but
you need to do that early on
and then
um then you know when you want to do a
nap that everybody can use radio is
pretty convenient for that because once
you have your pipeline the interface is
built immediately
so I would say you know it's important
you start with a pre-trained model if
you have one so that you benefit from
from its knowledge and you get results
quickly maybe you can freeze some
weights based on what you do or not but
this is what we would get after
after an hour so as you train as you
implement your pipeline you want to
monitor the progress you have a
different way of really logging your
your samples
um and then you consider Evolution but
at least observe them manually in the
worst case so after one hour of training
this is what we would get a farmhouse
surrounded by beautiful flowers I'm like
okay we're getting some kind of images
so hopefully hopefully it's doing
something but it's kind of suspicious to
you like is it really learning something
right and after five hours we get blobs
that start getting shape and if your
imaginative you're like okay I'm getting
the sky in some of the images
so it seems to be working after 15 hours
it has improved a bit you see some trees
maybe so like maybe it's working and
here is after after that three days
basically and you can see the the houses
you can see the flowers you can see the
sky so that that's when that's when it
works and that's when it was cool to see
to see a lot
so I'm gonna quickly conclude but
basically at the end the TPU died
because it was the end of the of the
competition and our validation was in
the in the last three in the last day
was still going down pretty nicely so
like oh it should be cool to to train it
a bit more we stopped the training early
and who knows what the moral could have
been
um we have very promising results this
is the sunset of our Green Mountains the
Eiffel Tower on the moon the armchair of
the universe Farmhouse surrounded by
really great results and we were like
okay let's train longer
so after that um I tried to train it
longer and turns out that she didn't
improve actually you know that TPU died
at the perfect moment it started over
fitting we had a small data set because
we had little time to prepare it there
was not that many cool resources to
preparate unlimited amount of memory
so I increased it it didn't really
improve
so that's when I was okay let's go to 1
billion
and one billion models started to look
pretty bad uh so that's why I'm gonna
end it but then started the the second
part of the story which is like a
building crayon and how hard to how to
solve it and you know like it was about
the the main things like you go deeper
you know you start from that hugging
face string script taking face model and
you slowly dive in and you get an
experiment that works and then you you
have new ideas you get into new frames
but you know you want to try and you get
excited about this and I think it's
really fun event and help you get a lot
of fun and learn a lot learn a lot with
it
all right and that's about it so now if
if anybody has any question
thank you so much uh Boris for this
presentation it was really fun to see
how it all came together and how it all
started with this uh competition and
it's also important to emphasize this
happen in the middle of 2021 right so
this is
the text to image process right and the
all the the amazing advancements we are
seeing now like even if today you look
at this and it looks oh
not that great at the time it was
literally the first time someone was
actually able to type a sentence and get
uh an image that looks very much like
what you were typing
um in their hands because there was a
dolly one blog post but it was a blog
post so this is also like when you place
it in time it's very exciting to see and
also the names that you mentioned the
the people that worked with you if we
look back what they're doing now it's
like everyone joined the space and now
they're like prominent uh they're
Founders like you or they work at
hugging face like Pedro and Suraj or
they are doing crazy new cool things
with the medical stuff like tennis so
it's really cool to see these Vehicle
Systems
um I have a few questions for you so
Alex asked us uh we're working on
they're working on a similar project
with a non-regressive VQ sampler and
he's asking if you have any advice
regarding training the final model in
hyper parameter finding
okay
so I would say you know if you find it
depends it depends a bit on your model
but if you look
um you can find you can find some
inspiration I would say in film one
model like listen during this model or
or other other models I don't know
exactly what you what you're trying to
do I guess you're trying to do a model
maybe like a muse
so for the final model I would say it's
always good to start with a smaller
model to see that it works because the
long model takes maybe a long time to
train maybe several days so you don't
get much feedback on your model or is it
training well and you may wait a long
time and not get any result I always
like to try to start with a small model
depending on your setup maybe 100
million to 500 million parameters which
is already quite big but it lets you see
that the model trains and often when you
when you start with a smaller size and
you go to the higher size the parameters
transpose pretty well so finding a
learning rate on a smaller model and
then going to the higher model
it's it's good because that the best
learning rate won't be too far off
there's fancy methods to have a learning
rate that ports well to larger models
but you don't you don't need them I
don't really understand them many times
I trade them but often you know when you
when you multiply the size of your model
let's say by three or five maybe up to
ten often the parameters don't change
too much I would say the main parameters
that will matter are the running rate
um what for your Optimizer use the
default it's fine
um whatever default your library keeps
or look at other implementations and use
their defaults they Define the default
that worked well and or look at the the
paper too that they had the time you
know they did the research they did a
lot of experiments use their parameters
and if you want after that you can play
a bit with some
um but the main one is the learning rate
and
do you know weight decay all that is
always is always tricky me I often don't
use it too much drop out the same I
don't use it too much
yeah
cool thank you so much
um there's another question from Alex uh
actually interested in the cryon uh
follow-ups so he's asking can you share
it in architectural differences between
Dali mini that was on the Sprint
compared to the most recent crime
versions he loves the name by the way uh
thank you uh so yeah the the difference
like the liminal is uh it's more like a
bot model and it's it should discrete
tokens and um and carry on the recent
version is more like a diffusion model
so it's a bit different it should be
closer to what you see in stable
diffusion or or imagine or or Delhi too
um they all they all use like a division
so that's when you you have an image
that you slowly denies you add a little
bit of noise and you try to remove it
and you do a few a few steps the elimini
predicts the image in in one just in one
iteration your new problem is because
it's a decoder model you have to to do
one token at a time so it's quite slow
diffusion model You can predict the
entire image at a time there's there's
ways that are a bit in between like the
The Muse model for example or the VQ
diffusion what they do they use discrete
tokens but it's a decoder model so you
predict all your tokens at the time and
then you mask randomly some tokens and
you predict them again and you kind of
mix that to meet the diffusion but in
discrete in discrete space
and it works quite well because you get
a bit the benefits of both so
oops I was muted cool and then we have a
last question from uh he asks you how
much of your TPU time were you able to
do the final run and how much was wasted
in experiments that in fail runs I think
you touched upon it a little bit but if
you could expand on that
yeah so actually this is a this is
interesting because often when you see
the the time that people train on tpus
they're like oh this experiment runs in
a week or runs in two days or in three
days but I would say that training time
is 10 of the actual time
uh the only things like you know I think
when people train on big machines you
first stop developing on a tiny machine
and then you run on the big machine
but a lot of the time is spent on um on
debugging and making it run so the final
training run was the last three days for
us but we had the machines for I think
two weeks the entire event was three
weeks I think we had them a week in and
you know it was understanding how to
connect to tpus in SSH basic things you
know um initially but um but yeah you're
going to experiment in collab even in it
and and you're gonna try to make things
run and the good things you have good
starting scripts that will let you let
you run things quickly but yeah there's
a bit of a headache at the time or like
you bang your head against the wall a
little bit because it's just your your
model maybe doesn't run at all and and
this is part of the spot of the game and
I think you know that the good things
like after you bend your head on the
wall a few times just once the machine
learns you're just so happy like okay
it's training and uh and it's a really
nice nice experience
well awesome thank you so much uh
uh Boris for your time and for your
presentation I think it was inspiring
for me and I hope it was inspiring for
everyone that is joining the uh Sprint
and we hope to see many Works uh
inspired uh in in Spirit by by the Dali
meaning process and I'm excited about
the cryon V3 uh that has been teased uh
do you do you have anything to talk
about it
um feel free to yeah not so it's the new
version is released in a few hours so
excited about it uh I think people have
been testing it already and like it and
I think it's just fun to see I just like
to see what people what people do with
this model so it's nice you know to to
let people experiment uh to me that that
comes back to the first images you know
not initially with dalimini our most
creative prompts were like the Eiffel
Tower on the moon or a cat with a hat
and then you let people use it and you
realize the explosion of creativity is
really nice and yeah I like the I like a
lot the the meme prompts there's a lot
of artists that do the nice images and I
like that but I like also the crazy
prompts the funny the funny things what
the model do so I hope I hope people
enjoy the new version too awesome Yes uh
I think dolly mimini was a meme machine
that is still unrivaled like I I mean
all the other image generators are
pretty fun but the meme vibe that the
alimini was able to provide I think is
still unparalleled and I sometimes go
back to cry on to like generate and also
I think the nine nine by nine grid is a
powerful uh aspect because sometimes the
images are complementary I've seen many
people like uh you type something and
then one image has like you have two
people fighting and then each image has
them and they are kind of facing each
other so it's kind of like the
randomness of the process helps with the
mimetic process as well yeah that's true
there's that one problem that's funny
like people but wikiHow and the type
something crazy wikiHow how to save a
cat that is becoming a demand or
whatever and and what's nice like each
one has a you have the nine grade and
each one it gives a story together
almost well the images our independence
you have kind of a story with the online
images so yeah it's it's fun
cool right thank you very much thank you
so much
see you soon bye
[Music]
all right so
our next talk will be by Margaret
Mitchell
um if you followed a bit of the news you
would see that she has been uh elected
one of the 100 most influential people
by the Time Magazine
and
basically she uh
has an interesting position in that
process because she has uh she's gonna
what the Time Magazine uh called a third
field that is either neither utopian nor
super dystopian this AI will change the
world uh either for for bringing the
Utopia or destroying the planet but
actually uh no one's view or a view that
is focused on what uh is here right now
but she can tell you way more about that
than me so I welcome you Margaret
Mitchell
do people
you see me and hear me I'm not sure I
think so yes
great
um cool so if I
exempt we have an
events to run through this
um but if I can present then I can go
through my slide deck yes so feel free
to yeah you can just share your
presentation and I can bring it up into
the into the stream okay
let me see here
I share screen
application window Opera tab
um
let's try this
how does this look does this look
reasonable at all or is it like filled
with
lots of tabs no it's it's just a
presentation so this is oh it looks good
yes
awesome cool
well thanks for having me
um and uh yeah thanks for arranging this
talk
um I was hoping to maybe shed a little
bit of light on ethical aspects
um of the text to image generation work
I think probably a lot of people are
aware of at least there being some kinds
of ethical issues
um but I thought it would be useful to
kind of summarize what the space is
um what kind of issues the space is
hitting on
um and some of the kind of priorities at
Play
awesome I'll let you do it
I'm Arrow
am I being
recorded yeah you're Live on YouTube and
this will be cool yeah cool available
afterwards okay great
cool so
um
this point people are mostly familiar
with how organizations and companies put
out all these different principles or
values
um that they use to define their work
um and that's actually one aspect of
what it is to operationalize ethical AI
work it involves identifying different
values at play in every decision in
light of current and foreseeable
societal impacts
um so for example many orbs have
narrowed in on things like uh
transparency and bias
um in the ethical AI uh image to or text
to image generation space
um some of the sort of concerns values
and priorities start with C so I like to
try and think of things that might be a
bit more memorable for people uh so in
the in the
um text to image space we can think of
the Seas of uh creativity copyright
credit consent and then the overarching
Paradigm that we're in of capitalism uh
so I'm going to go through each of these
a bit uh hoping to help make folks aware
of some of these different nuances at
Play
cool so the first AI generated image
that was sold for auction was created
using again and this was in um 2019.
it's this picture on the left here
um
portrait of Edmund uh Bellamy
um and the response was mixed uh at the
time this work was put forward it was
um very new to be able to show off this
kind of AI art uh to the art world to
the finite world and have it be
um taken seriously
um and people were
um nervous about it but also excited
about it
um and one of the interesting things
about this release was that
um the framing on what the image
um was was it was created by the system
it was the AI system itself being
creative
and that created some issues in how
people sort of approached uh
created some issues in how people were
like willing to engage with this kind of
Technology because then it started
bringing up the issues of like sentience
and Consciousness right so like can and
AI system be creative I'm going to break
that down a little bit
um but basically
um it was clear that more and more
artists were finding ways to use Gans as
tools for text images
um so these were people who
um we're able to think about things
artistically whether or not they had uh
formal training
um and use these as as essentially as
tools uh to create art themselves
um shortly thereafter another artwork
um from Mario klingerman was this
memories of Pastor buys one that's the
um that's the thing on the right
um and it generates portraits again with
Gans and it was sold at a Sotheby's
auction
um in both cases the artist ended up
pointing out that while the systems
create things sometimes in new and
interesting ways
it doesn't the systems don't do this
with intent
um and without a sense of what's
relevant it's the human The Interpreter
um who views and uh comes up with the
meaning one thing that clingaman said
was that
um it's like making a fire you can make
a fire and it produces interesting
interesting shapes uh but in the end the
fire isn't created it's you
hallucinating shapes and seeing patterns
AI is a glorified campfire
um so sort of interesting uh split
between the artists on the one hand who
were seeing this as a tool and something
that they were using in order to
generate art themselves and the way it
was talked about in more popular culture
which is that the system itself was
created essentially erasing the role of
the artists who put it together and I
think this caused a bit more of an
uproar than um it would have if the AI
was talked about more like a tool
um more recently diffusion-based models
have become the leading approach that's
why folks are here
um and it's further fired up the the
debate around art and AI
um so this work uh which is on the right
here is called uh theater the the the
spatial
um Opera theater it's the English
translation
um and it took home a blue ribbon at
Affairs context
um and a lot of people ended up
um complaining that this was essentially
cheating right so artists became more
and more nervous about their own Futures
why would anyone pay for art if it can
just be generated
um and this also brought up a lot of the
ethics of uh Ai and AI art Generation
Um more and more into public
Consciousness
um where one of the concerns was that
um systems that can do this are
essentially a high-tech form of of
plagiarism and you can see here's I just
copied one of the many responses from
from artists responding to this work
saying that part of the value of art is
in the process not the results
um and art has no value if the artist
can explain the process
um other people have complained that
um this art is not grounded in a
societal context and to be real art it
has to be grounded in societal context
or Human Experience
um but either way it's sort of
um it's either way it's clear that this
technology is doing something that's
that's incredibly remarkable
um and it's creating very sort of fierce
emotions both on the pros and the cons
uh of of them
of its ability to do this kind of thing
okay
um but actually it's fun to think about
this because you can go back in history
and see that this kind of thing has
played out before and then actually
learn from that in order to inform what
you can do moving forward and also like
it gives you some foresight about how
concerned you should be about different
kinds of things
um and so
um there was a lot of controversy for
example when cameras were first
introduced um and and still photographs
um so a lot of painters at the time so
this is like late 1800s when um still
photography was first introduced they
really recoiled at the idea
um they saw it as a debasement of human
Artistry
um
and then we have some nights closed here
one from baudelaire uh who calls it The
Refuge of failed painters to
ill-equipped or or lazy
um and that uh photog photography is
invading the territories of art
um and has become Art's most mortal
enemy
um and then a similar
um uh I should say a different view on
the same sort of topic was put forward
by D Levine who said the three the free
availability of the idea doesn't result
in a collapse of the market available to
the original innovator
um a lot of what's going on here with uh
text image generation is similar to what
happened with this fear of of
Photography taking over where uh art
artists who had put their heart and soul
into creating uh physically creating uh
these different kinds of images felt
that now there was this other thing that
could only make everything worse but
instead what we saw was that artists
picked up cameras as another form of art
it became a tool for the art that they
were
um wanting to create
um and uh
and then we were able to develop further
kinds of things like licenses in light
of modern photography
um and so we're probably going to follow
a similar sort of uh trajectory in the
development of uh text to image
cool so one of the concerns is around
um the people who have been input into
the training their data
um and and the fact that the Norms of
copyright and consent and credit
um aren't very clear they're not well
defined yet
um so the justification that's used uh
most often in the in the generative art
World
um is that you can use these images
because they're covered in the U.S by
What's called the fair use Doctrine the
fair use Doctrine
um which aims to encourage the use of
copyright protected work uh to promote
freedom of expression so when deciding
if something is fair use there's a ton
of different considerations
um and so there are two factors that are
particularly relevant to know about one
is
um the purpose or nature of the use and
the other is the impact on the market so
there are there are priorities around
whether the use case changes the nature
of the material in some way which is
usually described as a transformative
use and If it threatens the livelihood
of the original Creator by competing
with their works and it's that latter
aspect of our youth doctrine that is
increasingly now part of ongoing legal
discussions
um considering this it's much more
likely than not that the training
systems
um on copyrighted data will be covered
by fair use but the same can't be said
for the generated content
um and one of the areas where we can
learn from as well here is around music
and the music industry
um
one of the
um high-level takeaways from the
discussions of copyright here uh is that
if the model is trained on many millions
of images and used to generate novel
pictures it's unlikely that it
constitutes copyright infringement
because it's not
um it's not putting any particular
artist out of business
right the trend the training data has
been transformed in the process the
output doesn't threaten any Market of
any specific original art but if you
fine-tune that model on say a hundred
pictures of a specific artist and
generate pictures that match their style
that match their style
um an artist would have a reasonable
case against you
um and indeed that's starting to happen
um I want to uh talk about
something else that I'm worried I don't
have a slide for
um
so I'll just say that
um there are other Alternatives and I'll
get to those next okay so
um one of the ways that uh the artist's
work interact with ethics here and the
law is around their use of copyright
um and I think copyright laws really
misunderstood but essentially there's
this idea that if a piece of art is
copyrighted then it may be illegal in
some way to use it uh fair use Doctrine
sort of argues against this and says if
it's transformative then it doesn't
matter but one thing to know about
copyright in particular
um is that your work is under copyright
protection the moment it's created so
you don't need to register something for
it to be copyrighted it's copyrighted as
a function it's copy written as a
function of you creating it but then if
you ever want to pursue legal recourse
you have to
um have it already be registered so this
is why people do it
um
but in general it's sort of uh it sort
of agreed that uh that copyright exists
for the images that are on the web
whether or not there's this explicit
copyright
um uh Associated to it that you can see
um or that's been registered somewhere
um and still that these images that are
copyrighted are still reasonable enough
to pick up in training if uh there isn't
any one image or one artist who's over
represented
um and then the issue really comes into
play with copyright when it is art that
is um specific to an artist or some
specific style of an artist
um and this has uh ended up creating
some kinds of lawsuits so there are two
lawsuits right now uh to be particularly
aware of in this space
um one uh the one on the left is this
buttrick lawsuit
um which is making the case that AI
image generators are uh 21st century
collage tools
um and so they are comparing the
generated images to collages and trying
to talk about how
um uh
and how that like uh provides some sort
of parallels in whether or not this kind
of work can be done that relies on this
idea that
um the individual pixels that are
represented in in a text to image
generation system are somehow
connectable to an original image source
um there's uh I think a little bit of
debate about whether this lawsuit will
actually hold much ground
um in part because it does seem like the
fair use Doctrine
um would uh override you know the
concerns that are in in this lawsuit
um the other lawsuit is much more
serious
um or I think experts think is much more
likely to have a significant effect uh
and that's from Getty Images
um and basically uh Getty Images was
able to show this other kind of
generation where it's tied to some
specific artist or some specific style
and here the specific artist or style is
uh Getty Images
um as can be seen through the use of the
Getty Images logo right so this is this
position where it's um not the fact that
the image is generated from uh other
people's art it's the fact that it is
mimicking some specific style or some
specific organization in this case and
that's when the copyright issues really
um come into play
um most recently there's been some
advancements in how this works
um so copyright law is now updated
um to say that the output of a system
can be further copyrighted if there is a
lot of additional human work at Play
so uh previously it was thought that
maybe it wasn't possible to copyright
anything that came out of a text to
image generation system because it is a
collection of all these other people's
works and it's something that comes out
of a mechanical automated process but as
more and more artists have begun to
really use this as a tool uh use text to
image as a tool it's become clear that
the artist's work there is copyrightable
so to
say something
okay so to the extent that uh that
original artwork can come out of using
text to image models
um uh the human artists that create them
can to some extent copyright that that
content
um but outside of the legal doctrine of
copyright there are some more personal
uh or social values at play with respect
to how to recognize others work and that
is consent compensation uh and credit
and so
um one thing that's really interesting
is that depending on whether or not an
AI system is talked about as a tool or
an agent uh really affects how people
see the need to credit all the people in
the pipeline that lead to a generated
image so you can break apart the players
in some AI generated content as the
crowd so those are the people whose
whose data is mined the technologists so
that's like us the I guess is the people
who train the model
um there's the model itself
um and then then there are the artists
who use the model to create new art
um and depending on how you talk about
AI the public perception of who deserves
credit fundamentally changes even for
um the same kinds of images so the way
we talk about AI really really matters
when it comes to how we realize these
kinds of ethical values that are of
particular concern
um and what credit means is naming
people alongside their shared art and
the issue without credit is that it can
create marginalization and Erasure so in
the case where you have a text to image
generating system that's generating
images much like some particular artist
or organization that means that
they are they become less and less
relevant as this other work that is like
them but much cheaper is able to be used
and then with time uh sort of disappear
from the public consciousness
um so it's really important to give
credit when it's the case that
um a specific artist uh or or style is
is being copied and one way that uh
people can actually ask for credit or
have asked for credit in the past is via
Creative Commons licenses so this is
something I think most people are
probably familiar with you see it all
the time it says CC buy
all these Creative Commons licenses
there's a bunch of them CC by essay
ccvisa NC they're all sort of like uh
different variations on whether
something can be commercial shared this
kind of thing but they all actually
require attribution uh so this is sort
of a weird and has been a weird
conundrum for Big Data where on the one
hand
um you should be able to grab up all
this data as part of fair use uh on the
other hand they have licenses that
explicitly ask for attribution
um and then what do you do when you put
it through in a system where you have
actually no uh no way to to give this
appropriate kind of credit
um the thing about Creative Commons
licenses is that uh they're largely
developed in a different time right they
haven't been developed with the idea of
how machine learning works there's still
sort of uh stuck in this Paradigm where
you have one image and then that one
image can be shared other places and
that's sort of it there's in the sense
of like this Mass collection
um and so that means
um that a lot of the licenses
um that are available now aren't super
perfect for what people would actually
like
um and so we actually need to create new
kinds of licenses in order to address
these sorts of issues
um credit is inextricably linked with
consent
um which concerns whether an artist is
okay with their content being used so we
can talk about these legal doctrines of
of copyright of licenses
um but underneath that the sort of
spirit of that is around the consent of
the artists themselves
um and so I think it's important to be
aware that there's actually lots of
kinds of consent
um and if you want to respect the fact
that some artists do want consent then
you can play around with these different
kinds of mechanisms of consent
um so consent can be opt in or opt out
um opt-in is where you say yes my data
can be used opt-out is where you say I
don't want my data to be used and that's
something that um spawning has been
doing the have I been trained system
and there's a bunch of different kinds
of consent beyond that so there's
explicit consent and that can be
contrasted with implied or passive
consent where
um because you're participating in
something you're said to have consented
to it but that can be sort of you know
shaky legally
um and then there's uh informed consent
which is
um particularly valuable when trying to
ground on you know people's different
values and what they prioritize
um
so um this comes from a tradition of
autonomy and self-determination common
in metal medical work
um and it's basically uh the act of
obtaining consent after informing an
individual of all the possible outcomes
um I'll talk about that in a little bit
in a second
um I want to also hit on this idea of uh
continuous consent which is that every
time a subject's Jada is used they
consent again I don't know that there
are any mechanisms for that but that is
something that has also been developed
in the medical domain that can be
particularly useful for thinking about
consent mechanisms and I also want to
flag what I've called forced consent
this isn't actually a term that I found
people to use it's one I've made up
forced consent but it's a situation
where Alternatives exist but the
individual is only given one clear
option and so an example of that is in
airports it's quite common now to be
going through a line and suddenly like
facial recognition is going to be used
on you
it turns out out you can opt out but
generally the signs that say you can't
opt out are off to the side it's not
very clear the people running the face
recognition definitely don't tell you
that you have another option everybody
is trying to go through this line and
trying to do it quickly so there's a
sort of peer pressure to just get it
done and so this is what I call a forced
consent where basically there might be
some other option but you're really not
made aware of it and the situation is
one where it can be too difficult to
really do otherwise
um and so uh this is this is a just sort
of a
a way that consent can go poorly even if
you want to have some kind of uh opt-in
or informed consent
um without uh giving people you know
possible Alternatives then you
um you get them into a forced consent
sort of situation
but informed consent in particular
um is really useful to
um to know that this is exactly what the
person is okay with so it's probably
like the highest level of um like a
value-informed consent
um so it's an ethical and legal Doctrine
based on the assumption that all
interventions and this again is from the
medical field
um should be performed after a patient
or research participant has been
informed about the purpose nature
consequences and risks right so they're
given like this full scoping
um and it also includes uh the right to
withdraw and that's an important aspect
of this informed consent Doctrine
um I think I went the wrong way
[Music]
um cool and so um some things we can
take away from this informed consent
kind of Doctrine are these General
categories
um one I found one person who summarized
it as Park uh the recommended procedure
the reasonable Alternatives Etc
um I broke this down above in terms of
um AI a little bit so
um in the medical domain one of the
categories of consent is the diagnosis
applied to AI that would be something
like the intended use
another is the nature of the proposed
procedure in AI that would be something
like how the model or the application is
created
um in the medical domain it includes the
risk consequences and benefits of the
procedure you could say something
similar in AI instead of procedure it
would be application or model
um an assessment of the likelihood that
the procedures or for AI application
will accomplish the desired outcomes and
any reasonable or feasible Alternatives
um including
opt out so informed consent is a is a
relatively thorough way uh to to work
with uh people's values around consent
um uh even if there isn't a specific
legal Doctrine acquiring it
um I think I'm almost at time actually
um so I just have a couple more slides
um the notion of informed consent has
further sort of blossomed within the
digital world or within digital uh AI
ethics work
um and there's this project uh I think
it would be useful to be aware of called
um consentful Tech
um where they're trying to sort of
Define what good digital consent could
be
um it definitely borrows a lot from the
Notions of informed consent it also
um includes this idea of being
reversible which is often missed
um the freely given that uh that's
similar to mandating that it can't be a
forced consent so it can't be the case
that you can only use this system if you
consent to have your images used in this
way and you're really not given an
option otherwise
it has this additional idea that it
should be enthusiastic
which I think is quite ideal it would be
really awesome if everyone just
enthusiastically consented to things but
I think even like on enthused consent is
probably okay as long as it's consent
um but I think it's cool to see these
examples of projects that are really
trying to hit all of these really
important values kind of like maximizing
how many good things they can do in one
and this is obviously particularly
relevant in this kind of domain
um and just from my last slide I'll just
give a another plug here for spawning
um where they're playing around with
these opt-out mechanisms and will soon
be playing around with opt-in mechanisms
um most developers
um actually do want to be able to
respect consent if it's there uh and so
uh this work coming out of spawning I
think is a really useful path forward
for playing around with uh opt-in and
opt out consent mechanisms uh and in the
future maybe we can go to even more
informed consent mechanisms okay cool
thanks
uh this was an amazing presentation we
do have some uh audience questions if
you would be okay to taking them yeah of
course yeah
one is from uh come in Duru and he says
hi Margaret we have control net we
maintain full human control over AI
generated art with controlla doesn't
mean that the art creation process using
control net is copyrightable by the way
just for the record and for this call
even though like this event is not legal
advice I guess that's important to say
really say that yeah so please don't
take this this event as legal advice uh
we are not lawyers but we are talking
about the issues as they come uh but yes
so yeah yeah it's a really good reminder
I mean I'm approaching this as a scholar
of of AI and so studying ethics and law
kind of goes hand in hand um but yes I
can't give legal advice
um what I can tell you commanduru is
that um the copyright office in the US
has made it clear that it really is Case
by case
um so for any particular piece of
generated art um to be copyrighted it
must be the case that there has been a
large amount of of human work on it and
it's that human work that's copyrighted
not the image directly
um so it's it's it's a kind of tricky
situation where it's like something on
top of the the original piece of art
that's that's copyrighted it's the it's
the human nature of it
um so like the way that uh images could
be placed in a book for example that's
something that's that's copyrightable
um so
um yeah there's no easy answer to that
common Guru it's really a case-by-case
basis and and how much the people
working with the images are actually
putting their own artistic thought into
it
yeah and just to add to that I think the
there is a concrete example from what
you said which is someone tried to
copyright a comic book and then the
comic book image Arrangement placement
was considered copyrightable but each
Journey generated image was not so you
the arrangement in the page the
dialogues everything was copyrightable
on top but the each individual image
generated by by mid-journey was not
however I think it's interesting because
control adds like human control like you
decide which pose you want the image and
stuff and I think it's actually I would
encourage someone in this Sprint if they
generate a cool thing with the with the
control net to actually apply uh for for
copyright registration in the US
copyright office describe the process to
rolly and see because I think there
hasn't been yet one like this so it
would probably make the news if you do
it you'd probably be making the news
exactly so if someone wants to try to do
that there is is a fee so yeah you have
to be really invested in doing that but
it could be an interesting one
um there is another question for you and
it is by Shish uh and they're asking uh
you seem to be saying that if we
fine-tune a model on the style of an
author the model itself might be
infringing since this is not in the code
is there a case law to support it
um so so I'm not aware of the case law
for this and and one of the difficulties
with all of these discussions is that
there isn't a lot of case law there
isn't a ton of precedent for AI
generated content that said I don't
think I said anything about the model
being infringed
um most of the stuff I've read again not
being a lawyer or the model being
infringing most of the stuff I've read
is about the input and the output
um so really the the legal discussions
have been around the copyright and
licensing on the input images and then
the copyright and licensing on the
output images what I was talking about
with the fine tuning is that the output
of the fine-tuned model that mimics some
other artist that output
um can be subject to
um to lawsuits to Legal concerns and in
particular I pointed out the Getty
Images example where it seems like you
could see a specific organization that
was being mimicked it was because of
those outputs where there was an issue
um the model itself I'm I'm less I I
don't know about the model itself
infringing
all right well thank you so much for
your time I think we're reaching the end
of the your talk and of this event uh as
a whole thank you so much Mac and see
you in the next time
and everyone that joined this event I
would like to give a huge thank you
um this were three amazing days with
Talks by many different folk from Google
stability AI hugging face
um and essentially the idea was to give
you an overview about Jax about
diffusers ethical side
um how to train different models what to
control and I hope you had a good time
looking into this processes if you
haven't already I I we already started
distributing some tpus for the event so
go to the description join uh our
Discord servers and yes I will be
looking forward to talking to you more
uh if you would like to keep in touch
you can follow me on Twitter it's
multimodal art like you'll see in the
image and you we in also you will you
will be posting about the event in the
hugging phase uh social media as well so
make sure to be looking into that and
with that I will leave you and I have a
great day and I hope you have an amazing
event bye everyone
foreign